let's see if we're live
we should be live hi guys i hope you can
hear me
maybe you can run on the chat oh sorry
this doesn't start well
i have my ipad i have my my phone
the last time it was difficult to uh you
know deal with the chat
so i'm making sure that right now i got
everything figured out so let's see
um let me see if you can he should be
here
able to hear me and see me so welcome
back this is uh
live q a number two uh during the first
one i had a blast so i want to do it
again you asked a lot of interesting
questions
and we have one hour 30 maybe one hour
45
things get really interesting and i
haven't covered i i'm going to try to
cover
as much ground as possible because you
have so many interesting questions
i have printed some of the questions
that you asked me in the previous days
so i'm going to go through some of them
but also i'm going to try to reply to
all the questions
that you're asking me on the chat
starting from the top so
um just one more thing i want to say if
i don't reply to
all questions it's not because i'm
ignoring people
it's just because i have to select some
questions and
some of you have asked me very long
questions that it's going to be a little
bit complicated to read all
the entire texts so if you can just ask
you know short questions uh and to the
point so
uh without further ado let's get started
i'll ask i'll start replying some of the
questions that you asked me in the chat
before
uh you know this video started and uh
michael
uh greben i think he's he said i'm sorry
for butchering your names again
uh you said japanese is your weakest
language what level are you at
is it at least b1 one thing that i
always tell my students
and people i meet and also on on youtube
in general is that
i think that b1 a1 c1 they're just
labels i think that a more
proper question that you should ask
yourself in general you can ask someone
but you should first and foremost ask
yourself is
where do i stand what am i able to do
with this language
as far as i'm concerned for japanese i
do not know
it could be a two it could be b1 most
probably b1
but i think that more than
a label again i can tell you what i'm
able to do with japanese this is what i
do
at the at the beginning of every year
when i craft a plan
i'm gonna talk about it in one of the
next videos i ask myself where do i
stand what what am i able to do in terms
of reading
listening writing and speaking and it's
i think it's a much more appropriate
question i was divided into these four
main areas
so michael the answer is i'm not really
sure it's really rusty i haven't
so much has touched it in a long time
but i plan
on going back to it probably in a year
um because now i'm focusing on other
languages but i would say it's pretty
rusty
i can maybe have a conversation with
people in general i can read simple
texts but
uh really it's rusty and um and the the
bottom line is
i gotta go back to it because it's a
beautiful language and i would like to
go
visit japan sooner than later when this
pandemic is over
michael uh how many languages do you
want to speak in total that's the same
person
is there a number where you want to stop
adding new languages and start improving
the ones you
already speak i always say that a
polyglot
you know this label
they are able to learn more languages
more easily because they have a lot of
languages under their belt so to speak
but
it's more difficult to maintain all the
languages so in my case
um i don't know how many languages i
want to
be speaking in my life it to me numbers
are useless to me it's much
to me it's much more relevant actually
to be able to
use the languages that i learn in a
meaningful way so
if i can use four languages in a
meaningful way meaning traveling to the
country
um being friends with natives and living
experiences of four languages is much
better than just having
say 10 or 15 knowing 10 or 15 languages
and not using them so
for me uh i do not know how many
languages i want to speak in total it
doesn't really matter
i will figure it out on on the on my way
my existential path
and there is no fixed
number again 20 30. i will see i don't
think i'll ever stop
learning in general this is my mantra is
keep learning for the rest of your life
i've been living a journey for one year
i have been just speaking english
and even if i've been learning german
every day speaking is really tough i
read and write
decently but when i open my mouth i'm i
am at a loss do you have any advice well
my advice is to get a tutor
and you can find them on on youtube i'm
sorry youtube
you can find them on the internet it's
quite easy you have platforms like
italki for example or preply or
verballing
and then what i always say is that the
most important thing is to find a tutor
you like working with a person who is
really nice
and flexible that's single-handedly the
most important thing it doesn't matter
how competent they are
the most important thing and that
they're nice people and they're flexible
in terms of
when you ask them hey i would like this
lesson to be this way and
are you available at this time well that
these are the m much more important than
their capacity of explaining in-depth uh
grammatical
grammar notes or grammar the
nitty-gritty details of
of a grammar of a language and
and it might sound weird because sarita
says that she she's been living in in
germany for one year but it doesn't
matter what
the problem is that when you live in in
country
a lot of people do not have the patience
to correct you
or even when you go and interact with
people in shops then the problem is that
uh you know these are very short
conversations and
uh it's difficult it's stressful so
in to me sarah or
i would the advice would be my piece of
advice
is to find a tutor and just
connect with this tutor and build a
relationship a friendship with this
tutor and start speaking
the language in a protected environment
then slowly you can
you know start interacting more and more
with people this is quite important and
a lot of people have a hard time
speaking a foreign language because
stress is involved you're a little bit
uncertain about what to say
when to say it and you feel a little bit
judged this happens to everyone but
you have to speak and i would say
grab a tutor not literally and and start
start speaking you know start
interacting with them
so um gracias des de colombia amigo luca
gracias
marithia how can one remember how to
speak in the past tense
using sono or ho i'm not
sure i i understand this question
anderson polyglot how to keep fluency
level in different languages
is to build a lifestyle so in my case
i've built a lifestyle
that allows me to practice a number of
languages i use on a on a weekly basis i
speak
between let's say seven and nine
languages
um not every day of course but i'm
saying on a weekly basis because
i am a language coach so i teach people
i train
or coach people in different
combinations for example yesterday i had
a class
i i was coaching a russian person
learning german and we were speaking
german so i was giving all the
explanations in german
sometimes you know i train in italian
spanish
people want to learn for example english
or do the opposite so
in in my work i tend to use a number of
languages
that i have a team i communicate with in
italian english spanish and other
languages
so if you want to you know maintain
languages you have to create a lifestyle
on top of all this
apart from the fact that language
language learning is my job my job
revolves around hinges on
language learning i also um have a lot
of friends
from all over the world and i tend to
spend time with either online or offline
before the pandemic now we'll go back to
the new
the the old trend hopefully when this
pandemic is over
uh but it's a lifestyle it's a holistic
approach to language learning i
do not learn languages in a vacuum i
don't learn languages just to say that i
know a bunch of languages to be language
learning is something that has
profoundly changed my life and can
change yours um and um it's uh
i use languages all the time that's what
makes a difference so
if you want to you know maintain
languages you have to create an
environment in the right circumstances
for you
otherwise it's going to be quite
difficult to maintain languages because
unfortunately
maintaining languages is something that
requires a lot of time and energy and
you want to
you know build things right build the
right circumstances
marco philippe says since you don't use
anki what type of
srs space-time repetition do you use for
vocabulary
that's a big one but basically
to make a long story short i use
notebooks
short notebooks and in general what i do
is i first i use my bi-directional
translation method
where this method has the entire space
repetition system
integrated in the method itself so
now it's it might take a little bit
might take a lot to explain how the
method works in detail but to
again for the sake of brevity and
simplicity
this you know i make sure that i repeat
repeat things
in a smart way and i use notebooks when
it comes to
repetition in general when i've hit for
example say the
the intermediate level b1 i tend to
um work on my
length my target language during the
week by exposing myself to the target
language watching videos
uh listening to podcasts with
transcripts etc and then i make sure
that at the end of the week
i just basically pour i transfer all the
information
into my notebook or notebooks and i have
a notebook for each different language
and then i have created a habit of
reviewing them having
a review system that is really uh
kind of special and works really well
for me now i can't go into the detail in
the details here but
um just for again for the sake of
brevity and simplicity
writing things down especially fragments
not just single words that are relevant
and useful for you they can you reuse
and review them regularly a couple of
minutes a day
is really making a difference in my uh
in
in my retention workout your retention
and across a wide range of languages
i do this more often than not with
languages i'm actively learning of
course not the languages that i have in
maintenance mode quote unquote
so john how important is repetition is
it better to read a thousand sentences
once or one sentence a thousand times if
the answer is somewhere in between how
do you find the right balance i said
before it's yes as
i was telling marco i think the
um the balances in between um you have
to find a way to repeat
words so if you see a word just once
your brain is not going to remember it
so you have to make sure that somehow
you find a way to repeat to to get
exposed to the same
word or vocabulary but you have to make
sure that you do it in a smart way
repeating in a dull way over and over
is not a very good way to um
to learn things there is a great book
which is called the truth about how we
learn by benedict carey
should be somewhere up here now i don't
remember where it is right now
uh but uh maybe kevin uh by the way
kevin
and berta they're you know my team
members and they're
in the chat as moderators they will um
write all the uh the links of the
resources i'm going to
um to quote and um this this book the
truth about how we learned by benedict
cary is a fantastic book that talks
about
how to repeat the smart way it's not
just about language learning i actually
do not talk about language learning they
talk about how college
students can learn in the united states
and across the world can learn better
so this is these are precious pieces of
advice that you can actually
leverage and harness yourself to learn
anything
and uh basically the bottom line is you
have to find a system where you repeat
the information
but you reuse it first so when you
say want to repeat words always grab
fragments
small fragments of speech that are
interesting for you and then
at specific um moments of time you have
to make sure that you reuse them in a
smart way either you talk to yourself or
you make sure that you reuse them in
some
conversation that you can have with for
example that you plan on having with
your tutor
um so uh
but he's not but i'm nice
love i think i look i have a question
i'm currently learning four languages
english italian
latin and mandarin any advice on how to
organize
the thing i would say is that learning
four languages at the
same time is quite quite
the defeat so to speak is quite the
challenge
if i were you if you really want to
learn pursue four languages at the same
time
the piece of advice would be my piece of
advice would be to
find maybe 10 minutes or 20 minutes
to cover each language every day because
unfortunately
i fortunately or unfortunately i believe
that if you want to learn a language
well you have to learn it every day if
you do not learn a language every day
then you're sending your brain the wrong
signal or the wrong signals
your brain gets confused when you've
learned your own native language you've
been
speaking and using that language every
single day
but um if you say let's let's say let's
grab mandarin right
if you learn it every three days which
is something that a lot of people do
they
rotate they say oh i have two languages
so i do one
one on you know let's say i don't know
latin and mandarin i do latin on
monday and mandarin on tuesday and latin
on wednesday
and mandarin on thursday et cetera it
confuses your brain
so when you when it comes to learning a
language you should learn every single
day
the problem is if you have four
languages you should learn four
languages every single day
and the more languages you have the more
difficult it is to do that every single
day
i am learning by myself i'm learning
hungarian danish and
greek at the same at the same time every
single day is difficult
to do it every single day is difficult
so my piece of advice would be get
organized maybe if you
are fresh in the morning and you
dedicate at least 15 minutes to each
language for one hour a day
it's much better than in my book to
rotate this is what i would say
plan beforehand and decide that for at
least one hour a day you do 15 minutes
of each language uh
let me scroll down um
so you have a hin
i think it's a georgian name so i'm not
sure
how to pronounce that but you you asked
whoever you are hi luka when uh
when should you when should we start
practicing to view videos in your target
language without looking at the
subtitles i always say you can always
watch it with subtitles
some people comment come to me and say
hey should i watch it without subtitles
but um
if i want you with subtitles isn't it
cheating it's it's not cheating
i always watch even movies in english
with subtitles because there's always
the possibility of not understanding
something
because someone speaks of a weird accent
there's a you know some background noise
so i think that uh subtitles make
any video comprehensible and if you are
bothered by subtitles that's a different
matter
but i think that if you keep watching
stuff with subtitles there is no harm in
it um
let me see here what's the time in your
country everyone okay this is not a
question about language learning hi luca
i'm just scrolling down from the
beginning because the other time
when i was scrolling down to the bottom
it was getting very confusing so i'm
reading one
because it was you know messing up the
um
you know the the chat for me so to read
all your questions
almost i'm i'm i'm skipping some
questions so sorry guys if i skip some
some questions it's just uh to make this
um
you know more modular so to speak
um so i'm still learning
high privilege
so let me see uh
like english with lucy i met lucy i
don't know if you guys
know lucy she's a wonderful she's a
wonderful girl i met her in berlin when
we met all the youtubers
we met a couple of years ago that was
organized by my friend
gabriel and it she's she's a fantastic
girl she gave a great speech
about her experience on youtube
fifa fifa merced i think you're from
probably from brazil
i think i've seen you before do you
think i mean see you online
do you think taking a language
proficiency exam is beneficial to the
student
in terms of helping him or her improving
their knowledge in the target language
absolutely uh but again and this goes
back to
um the book i was i was quoting before
is uh it's really important to use it as
a learning tool we also
we tend to interpret these things as
almost a punishment right oh they're
going to give me a
i'm just going to run a test and they're
going to give i'm going to get a good
good or bad mark never think in terms of
performance always
think in terms of learning if you do
this mental shift
if you start thinking that every single
experience you go through is a learning
experience everything changes
so say if you sit on an exam and then
you get a bed mark
and then you go back home despondent and
you think oh i've done so poorly at this
exam i flunked the exam
that's i don't think it's a good way of
seeing things and if you go back and say
oh i've learned a bunch of things i
don't know if you ever happened to you
guys
if you you know sit on exam you flunk
but then you go back and you look look
at the solutions
for example mathematics physics but also
history whatever
and then you realize that by doing a
test you learn a bunch so
if you learn to use tests in order to
learn as learning tools then everything
changes i have
here i hope you can see it i have
uh this is suppressing
so that's c2 of good institute that i
did
um it was uh i think
10 years ago there was uh something like
that then i have all these
uh for uh i hope you can see it i have i
bought all these
that i use with my students so a lot of
my students have
you know they actually done the these
exams in spanish german
i have a few more here actually i think
i have like
i don't know a lot so i have this is
still good
institute then you have then satisfied
that
bits five so these are all uh resources
i'm using with my students i'm i'm
i'm training them to basically use
these books in a in a in a new way right
it's not just a book in and of itself
but always how you use it it really
makes a difference so
uh a melo i think that's your name
because the rest is difficult to
pronounce fifa macedo
they're amazing tools if you know how to
do them and i always
recommend that you actually
you know that you you you do these exams
if you can because you can really learn
a bunch from them i myself i want to sit
i have two i've
i've done four exams so english french
spanish and german
and i want to now i want to sit the
polish exam c1
and i want to do that in varshava when
in warsaw or vava as some people call it
in in poland
at the end of the year and i talked
about it with my instructor my polish
instructor she's also a good friend of
mine
ngocia gosha hi if your chest if you're
watching this
we talked just one hour before this this
and um
and it's great i'm excited
because uh because i'm using the excuse
this exam as an excuse
to uh to get polish
you know to the next level so to speak
so let me scroll up because
guys you've i've seen here so many
questions
and now i got lost so
um let me i'm just scrolling up to
a point otherwise um this is going to be
uh complicated joaco juan cuando de
sierra
when do you start you know decide to
watch um movies
and and tv series without subtitles i i
think i i replied before
uh joachim or joaco that
i watch stuff with subtitles um so
always with subtitles no matter the
language no matter the level because i
always
think that it's beneficial to watch
something with subtitles as
comprehensible
comprehensible input
so languages with kuro which first
advice would you give to a beginner
polyglot or person who wants to learn
more languages gracias saludos testa
lucia
beautiful andalucia been there some oh
some time ago
i think 12 years ago just amazing
my advice should be to pursue
a life of learning and believe
and have the strong belief that
languages can change your life but they
should not just
be language stuff that you accumulate
you should avoid the
hoarder syndrome in other words thinking
oh when can i be called a polyglot with
three four or five languages
doesn't matter it's much more important
to learn one language well
use it live it live experiences get into
no interesting people and move on to the
next one so
my piece of advice for a beginner
polygon or person who wants to learn a
bunch of language is that
do not get obsessed by languages and and
see languages as tools that can change
your life
and can change the vision that you have
towards the world not things that you
accumulate
this is the reason why i'm giving you
this piece of advice is because i've
seen a lot of people
um i call them hoarders right
you know they've been bitten by the
public bug so to speak but not the good
bug
um so uh are you thinking of learning
arabic yes
i i have it here
so i already have uh i think the camera
has to adjust i already have
a larabeau i don't think it's going to
be census force so that is without
effort
but um yeah i want to learn arabic i
don't know exactly when this is going to
happen but already
about the book and when i buy the book
normally it's going to happen
so um david solis
hi luca my first goal is to read
literature in my target language but i
get terrified in front of the books even
having a good amount of vocabulary could
you give me a piece of advice so
i'm not sure whether you get terrified
by books because
i guess you get intimidated by the idea
of reading them right because you maybe
you get
you know one one thing that happens
happened to me
is that when i learn a language for some
time then
i get slightly intimidated or slightly
anxious
about the idea of reading a book and
getting disappointed for not
understanding this is very common
my piece of advice would be start with
books that are easier
so yes sure you want to read
masterpieces
of written in your target language let's
suppose that you're learning say
russian just to give an example or
german french
beautiful literature but i would not
start reading
uh these gigantic books if you have say
a b1
because reading books is a complicated
it's a complex skill
and you have to have a lot of vocabulary
and vocab and there's a high chance that
you're going to get
you're going to be at a loss with books
that are really complicated i will
always take it one step at a time
i would get a kindle for example that
even if i
tend to use uh to read on paper the
kindle has the advantage that you can
look for words you can just push
on on the word itself you see the word
and then it gives you directly the
meaning so it makes it easier to look
for words
and the other thing is i would go back
and and start reading books that you
have already read and that are
relatively short
that simplifies the reading because once
you understand the content of a book
already
you already read it it's much easier to
read it in a foreign language or you can
use graded readers
maybe i can find it here i have a
graded reader in chinese just to give an
idea
how cool it is but now yeah i can see it
here so
for example these are very cool i don't
know if you can see
uh this is a graded reader in chinese
the thing about
see it always says it also has you know
this this cool stuff this is this is
special for chinese
right because you can for example uh
the chinese let me just show you the
page here
so you should be able to see it
hopefully and you can use this to cover
the pinging so to cover the
transliteration
but the bottom line of this is these are
these are called graded readers so this
is called graded chinese right graded
reader chinese reader
number two and then you have number
three uh this is called selected
abridged chinese contemporary short
stories
uh and and um it's great this this stuff
is great
uh they're producing more and more
graded readers
i would not recommend you read stories
for
children unless you like them but they
happen to be
more complex than you can imagine so
there's a very common piece
you know piece of advice or maybe
stereotype that oh read
read stories for children unless it's
really the
it's really simplified language it's
written it's been simplified
um a lot of books that you know
uh are famous for being great books for
children etc the little prints as an
example they're not as easy as they look
so starting with books that you know
that you
maybe already read in your own native
language or great readers is
much better and don't worry everybody's
intimidated by
big books but don't start with big books
otherwise it's gonna get
it's gotta get tough i did that i
learned
my hard lesson when i did the um you
know the i
started reading it uh and i still have
it
it's it's the re the original version as
i think it's back here because we have
two lines of books
and i was painstakingly chatting you
know looking for every word
but i would not redo it now so
um let me see here
trevor alfred do you sample languages
before committing to fully learning them
what are
signs for you that you want to keep a
language in your in your life the signs
come from my
from from my life so uh it's a very
it's a very interesting question trevor
um i don't really
sample languages meaning that when i
told you with the idea of learning a
language normally then i go for it you
know
i don't dabble with languages i don't
likes
even if i understand that there's some
merit in just going around and saying
you know you go to a country and say hi
in the in the local language and then
you get a smile
beautiful i've done that before but it's
really not satisfying for me
when i when i when i speak a language
when sounds get out of my mouth i want
to speak that language so
uh you know i've been toying with the
idea of learning serbian and now i
decided to learn serbian
and what i normally do is i jot down the
date it's normally in september so
serbian is going to happen in september
and uh and then i go for it you know
so and the signs uh the signs normally
appear later well they appeared before
because you know maybe i went to for
example the balkans i was in belgrade i
really like
serbian culture etc but then once you
start learning the language
it's like things started hap
start happening or better i start seeing
things that weren't there
before but i didn't see them so it's
this amazing feeling when you start
speaking language and then you realize
oh
those people are actually from turkey
now i imagine that i'm
you know i decide to learn uh turkish
before you don't even notice
but then that reinforces uh your
you know the strength of your decision
so it's both before and and later but i
don't
i sample languages for a very brief
period of time and then
if i decide to you know to go for it
then that's it and then it's for life
i see languages like friends uh for me
friend when i when i make friends with
someone
it's for life well real friendship of
course
so um gents brian what is your opinion
about the education system in high
school don't get me started about this
uh i'm kidding i have here i jotted down
another question which is i wanted to
um to read because it's very similar to
um to yours and let's see if i can find
it yes
so it's by polyglotta africano
and he said polyglottafikanohai if
you're there i asked a question last
time but you didn't respond sorry about
that but as i told you
uh you know i sometimes i skip questions
because you you guys are so great and
you ask so many questions
i asked a question last time you didn't
respond how do you implement the methods
used by polyglots in school so that
learners don't get bored and they also
benefit
so um i do not
think very high of the education system
across the world but
um i don't know if you ever heard of i
think i talked about this in the last q
a
um finland is a very peculiar case of
how
you can turn a relatively um
inefficient system into a fantastic
system
and if you go there's if you go on
youtube
you're already on youtube and you by the
way and there's a
documentary by michael moore that talks
about that he he goes to finland and he
asks people he asks the finns directly
what is it that you're doing right
and then there's a whole there's a whole
story behind it
so i think that in general we have a
system that is based on knowledge
more than uh skill it's not skill
building it's more
knowledge building so wherever you are
in the world i'm pretty sure that
you know gone to school in high school
you figured out that
most of the time they do not teach us
how to learn
we don't know how to learn when i when i
hit university i didn't know how to
how to do how to solve really solve
problems they given us about for example
for mathematics they had given us a lot
of
equations and then just told us just
apply the equation
and that's it it's it's a very um it's a
very inefficient way
of uh of teaching anything and this has
been my experience and that has been the
experience of a lot of
students that i've have the pleasure of
coaching and a lot of people
i have the pleasure of talking to you
about the education system
and this is particularly uh jarring when
it comes to language learning
so lingering is a glaring example of
the fact that after five years of high
school or college
for that matter people cannot string
sentences together they might know a lot
of length and they might know a lot of
words
but they actually cannot speak the
language and this is because
you know you you build skills by doing
stuff
and i get the impression with a few uh
great exceptions that people tend to
speak
about languages rather than speak the
languages themselves at school that's
the main difference so
if i had to implement uh i would do a
bunch bunch of things i've given this
speech in scotland about how to change
the entire education system and i have a
i think maybe kevin can can can link can
write a link that we have a link on the
uh we have an article on the blog
talking about what i would do to change
the language
system uh you know the education in
general implementing more things how for
example
meditation how to use the internet
emotional intelligence
and obviously language learning and when
it comes to language learning what i
would do um
you know a typical let's say normal
week for me would be to watch with my
students would be to watch one or two
videos
uh to to
films to movies with subtitles to have
discussions to
to have them you know work in groups to
solve
language problems to have them play
games speaking languages and to speak
languages most first and foremost
and then you um you know i would um
definitely learn teach them grammar in
an indirect way
i've laid out some details there this is
very long
to explain and this is the philosophy
uh by which i abide and with a little
bit more effort
and a little bit of reflection everybody
could learn a language
very well at school it's just that the
system is a little bit old it dates back
to the industrial revolution it has
never changed
and it's a big elephant that is
difficult to change for a number of
uh reasons that range from political
reasons economic reasons et cetera so
some people haven't figured out that we
live in an era where the internet has
pretty much
changed everything and we cannot keep
going for a long period
of time this is not sustainable sooner
or later the system is going to crash in
a way and this is already happening
when it comes to higher education
university etc
because because the internet has really
changed the way we think and we conceive
information
how we consume information and how we
can you know
actually take things to the next level
language running is no exception that
in that regard so
claudia longifarina asked me
i know it might sound like which which
authors do do you prefer which
italian authors do you prefer italo
calvino
i think is just an amazing writer he's
my favorite writer
italo calvino umberto echo is also a
great guy carlo rovelli i don't know if
you ever heard carlo rally he's a
he talks about physics but i really like
the way he writes
but these two on top of everybody else
and might be a little bit verbose at
times but
you know italo carbino is one of my
favorite books
and it's one of those books that really
changed uh changed the way i see things
when i was a little kid i read it and
it's one of those rare books that when i
reread it i had the same beautiful
uh feelings and uh i don't know about
you guys but i love
i love reading and i read all all the
time you know whenever i can especially
at night
i i i'm almost like a kid at night when
i start
going back when i started going back to
reading ito calvino's books you know
thanks for the question i always love
talking about uh
you know about reading and books um
so who's saying how can you make balance
between new words and keep practice well
you just
jot down all the new words that you
especially in fragments that you want to
uh that you want to use and you find uh
find interesting ways to use them in a
conversation with your tutor or for the
people you
you you can talk to that's this is what
i would do so you kill two birds with a
stone you have
uh the best you you get the best of both
worlds as as they say
anya luca will make a video about your
library yes my bookshelf i will
definitely make a video in 2020
2021 and uh i just have to figure out
the best way to do it because there's so
many books and i want to
you know depending on we we will send
you
a few questions about the you know what
you want to see in this library because
there's a lot of stuff so
if you're really interested in language
learning there's a specific
place where i have all the books about
language learning but i have also books
about pretty much everything because i
like
everything especially cosmology physics
mathematics
uh quantum mechanics geopolitics so it
depends on what you want to see
um robinson
you still have in mind up to uploading a
video speaking about practice
speaking about practice speaking with
yourself so
yeah we'll i think i'll do that as well
it
might be an interesting video alejandro
garcia where we could find more
information about biodirectional
translation system
i have um i think maybe kevin can can
can drop a
you know there's a youtube uh you can
put a link kevin there's a youtube video
that talks about that by the action
translation that's uh
um a speech i gave in tessaroniki in
greece
and um in 2016
and there's also a couple of if you
write the biodirectional translation
system luca lampariello on google you
will find also some other
um some other interesting um
articles um i give normally for people
really what you're serious about the
bi-directional translation that is a
method i used to
start learning any language i just
finished a week ago
a live group and for those who
want to sign up to the mailing list we
have more surprises this year
so i just ran the second batch with uh
20 students and this is going to get
bigger
uh probably we're going to open it to
100 people where
you can get to know an entire community
and you can learn the bi-directional
translation so many
techniques i'm super happy because we
have just finished the second one
and everybody was enthusiastic about it
but
that's you know a higher level there's
more details and
it's it's not for free but having said
that
uh you'll have a lot of free information
you can find on my blog and also you can
find it on the internet because i give
interviews talking about the method and
you can watch
a one or two hour video that where i
talk about that
in and you know during the polygamy
conference that took place in
thessaloniki
um do you still study english
systematically or do you just
expose yourself to it uh michael i think
you this is your third question you're
very inquisitive guy i like that
um i do not
learn english systematically anymore i
just use it but i
never forget that first english is a
foreign language for me and second i
will never stop learning uh that you
know while we're talking there are more
words getting into this
the so-called uh you know pool of words
of vocabulary
in in within the english language so
you'll never
languages an entity that changed that is
a
living entity that changes in time and
space so you will never really catch it
but uh i pursue a life of learning so
for me
the most important thing is the act of
learning itself i do not study english
systematically but i use it all the time
and whenever i stumble upon you know i
don't know expressions that i don't know
i know i jot them down because they want
to know them
and this even if my learning curve has
considerably slowed down i'm always
um very appreciative of all the feedback
that you guys give me when i make a
mistake on youtube or when i make
i don't know mispronounced words that's
that's gold i found all these
uh you know pieces of feedback very
helpful to
keep refining uh my skills
so um let me see who has a lot a lot of
questions to answer he will try to get
as many as possible kevin says
yes i will try to do that
he is
yes i want to learn serbian starting uh
on
um starting in september um i have
i already have my
friend branca hi branca i'm pretty sure
you're watching this because you told me
you will watch it
and i will most probably work with her
at the beginning but
any help is much appreciated um
so jens what is your opinion about the
education system already answers this
question
uh a lot of [ __ ] i hope
i didn't butcher your name do you work
as an interpreter if you do how do you
find this job i've never worked as an
interpreter i have actually worked as an
interpreter but unofficially i went to a
conference interpreting school in paris
for one year
but then i decided that that was not the
path for me it's a wonderful
it's a it's an intriguing um it's an
intriguing job it's very demanding
and i if you want to go for it and if
you feel like you have this
uh you know you you want to you you like
interpreting it it's fantastic
but it's really demanding and one of the
things that one of our teachers i think
was the italian teacher
there because i was doing italian uh
italian was my my native language so now
my working languages were english
french and german i think the italian
teacher said if you want to be an
interpreter you have to focus on three
languages you have to give
most of your time and energy to these
three languages because you have to
constantly get updated about you know
everything you have to read newspapers
understand
the nitty-gritty details of pretty much
cultural things and it's really
demanding
and i remember once my teacher got upset
because
i uh we you know she had seen that i was
learning
japanese and she said what are you doing
that book and i said well i'm learning
japanese you said yeah but you're in a
very difficult
elite interpreting school so you have to
focus on just three languages
and i couldn't help thinking that that
was not i i don't want to
give up on stuff you know of course of
course
there's the saying jackal traits masters
of none and that's true but
i just figured out with time that i
didn't want to be an interpreter but if
you want to go for
for it i you should definitely give it a
try remember that it's tough
there's a lot of competition it's very
demanding and you need some unique
skills
either i mean you have to develop some
unique skills
but it's definitely worth it
spaces
i feel great he's asking how do you feel
about understanding so many countries
and
and um and languages i feel great and i
feel that
it has definitely changed my life it's
not about
you know i i'm very glad about uh the
fact that i started this youtube channel
because
um i think that getting out there
creates serendipity serendipity in your
life it allows you i've met so many
people thanks to
youtube you guys are great you know you
and all the people
along my uh the path that have helped me
so it's great that language learning has
brought a lot of things
um in my life but i think that the most
important thing is that
it has brought about a major shift in
the way
see the world so i see the world in in
brighter colors so to speak i really
can't put words i can't really explain
how to describe this but it's just you
know
you know the movie the matrix right all
of a sudden neo sees the world
as it is reality as it is not as people
perceive it now i'm not comparing myself
with neo
but in a way i see beyond
you know a monolingual person doesn't
get the things that i get
at a party just to give an example i
understand all the cultural nuances
if they speak languages that i know the
misunderstandings that
is just it's just mind-blowing and also
it brings about a different way you see
you you see your life so i always say
that oh it's always worth learning even
one language and even poorly because
um language learning is a life-changing
thing
so um
so uh jesus
look i really need you to say to
everybody tell everybody how to profit
from languages by becoming
translators and interpreters have you
got an advice a piece of advice about it
for us
i would just say if you want to be if
you want to be a translator an
interpreter
so be it first you have to like it and
both translators and good translators
and interpreters
make money but most of all you have to
always remember to do the things you
love
and you know steve jobs
said it at harvard right of that harvard
speech you said
your job is going to be a big chunk of
your life so you better
love what you do and you better do what
you love that's the most important thing
you have to keep in mind so um i would
say the most important thing is that
first you have to just
first you have to like it and you become
a good translator and or interpreter
very different jobs uh then you know
that's that's fantastic for you
zero five i don't know uh how do you
work on your accent
what would you do if you really want to
get to native like accent that's a long
one that's a big one
um it's it's complicated to answer this
question in just a few words but
i i was i would say that
the most important thing when it comes
to acquiring good pronunciation is
always start from the get-go start from
the very beginning be interested
and learn to notice things and do not be
obsessed
fourth do not be obsessed about obsessed
about speaking like a native you will
never
exactly speak like a native because
accent is tied to your identity and if
you were not born in that country you
will
not be a local but you can start
again the the you know
you have to get into the habit of of
training obviously and noticing things
one thing that i always say is that slow
down
you know slow your speech down so you
can start actually giving mental space
to your speech a lot of people do not
know how to monitor themselves when they
speak but if you start changing one
parameter of your speech patterns or
your speech production
then you can actually start seeing
things and noticing things
but to to make long a long story short
you have to get from the
you you have to start from the very
beginning you have to be
extremely interested you have to learn
how to train your ear there's a lot of
courses out there that you can take for
example if you just started learning a
language in whatever language
maybe not the most exotic ones but for
sure in english french spanish
russian you will find courses that help
you with that
so there you know give you a lot of tips
and tricks about how to
you know position your mouth um muscles
uh
you know the correct position of your
body also counts because it's not just a
mouth but it's also
uh all the rest of the body you we
produce language with
the entire part you know this this part
the trunk
so to speak so uh
sorry if if this is rather brief but it
would take me
three hours i you know have entire
courses on pronunciation i've given
entire courses
privately about how to do that but i
hope this piece of advice helps
distinguish
how how not to mix up two languages that
are very similar in my case german
and dutch it really depends on the level
you have in these two languages so one
is
surely more prominent so to speak than
the other and
uh one way not to confuse them is to
make sure
that you practice them every single day
on a daily basis because that way you're
not confusing your brain one thing that
really
that often happens is that a person say
imagine now
anna that you have been learning german
for quite some time you speak well
but then you move to holland and you
start speaking
dutch and then you get friends and you
know and you speak dutch all the time
then after a year
of just speaking dutch if you try to
speak german what happens is that every
every time you speak german dutch comes
out of your mouth you know
comes into mind and this is because
it's uh it's called the survival uh
survival of the busiest
or something along those lines means
that your brain
you have to use stuff for your brain to
be not to become rusty and this
unfortunately is how it works speaking
skills degrade very quickly if you don't
use your languages
so um one thing that i found to be true
in my case is to
when a language starts getting in the
you know in the background or the back
burner
i divide i design ways to
start doing something with it somehow
the best
would be to uh to speak both languages
at the same time
but then it really depends on the
situation it depends on a number of
factors now i don't i don't know you
i i don't know there's there's a lot of
factors that
um you know make a difference when it
comes to mixing the two languages
you know but it depends on the story
which one did you learn
first which one are you using more now
uh
so it really depends on the situation on
your personal circumstances but i would
say that
um for the like of brevity and
simplicity you should try to speak them
more or less every day uh both of them
and get
you know enough exposure to both of them
so you're telling your brain both
are important because if there's there's
a
there's not a balance there's an
unbalance between the two then it's
normal then one gets more
you know in the way than the other and
you have more
uh you have a harder time speaking one
more than the other
so um
so chat use beta says use only english
so everyone can understand what you're
seeing i'm reading the questions
directly in the languages but
that is is right it would be better if
you write in english
i know that we can speak a bunch of
languages but i would like to you know
we're talking about language learning
and learning how to learn a language
we will make possibly if you're
interested uh more live
videos um about in spanish for example
or just in italian
just to start with and then in other
languages but just to keep it
more like compact and simple
um kareem greetings from uh iraqi
kurdistan
uh greetings from rome italy uh have you
ever
tired teaching a language that's a very
interesting question have you ever
gotten tired i guess you are wanting to
say teaching a language no because i
love it i love i love coaching i don't
exactly teach a language but i love
coaching sometimes i get tired
if i have seven classes in a row for
example friday is my student's day
so i get tired physically tired but i'm
not tired of
you know coaching i'm more physically
tired because it takes a lot of energy
to plan a lesson build a lesson prepare
less and
give a lesson and and follow suit
so um greetings from romania
uh fantastic i have to visit go visit
sooner or later
so uh
where did you learn russian at home like
you know i just
let me see here if i can find it
yes so i started with this in 2014
maybe you can see it i hope you can the
camera has to adjust
logitech and uh i
so i i think the more relevant question
is not
yeah it's not where it's more like how
you learn russian so i started with
asimil
and then um and then i
made a youtube video in 2028 so i
started learning a language
to that russian in 2004
if i am correct
i didn't write it here i thought i had
so i started learning in 2004
and then for for a year it went really
well then
you know fell out of touch with the
language
and then i um i started learning again
give me a lot
youtube making that youtube video in
russian at the beginning
gave me a lot of enthusiasm and
motivation so i started learning again
and then i met my ex russian girlfriend
in moscow when i went to a conference i
got
i got to know her there and then i
started using basically
russian more and more on a weekly basis
i went to on a daily basis actually i
went to
russia and multiple times and that
really helped me
hone my my improve my russian
john i guess gnl hi luca can you fix an
accent after
20 years of bad speaking habits it's
quite tough you have to imagine like
having a knot
so this i always use the metaphor of the
knot the knot is extremely tight if you
want to untie it it's going to be
very very tough i always see the bright
side and the silver linings of things
but after 20 years of of speaking the
language poorly with the poor accent
it's gonna be tough uh to um fix
the accent or reduce the action whatever
whatever you want to call it
and then you know you should
i i think you should aim at uh getting
maybe slowing down
trying to be as clear as possible uh but
fixing your habits when it comes to
pronunciation after 20 years
that's going to be tough so um
uh outer face i like the name otter face
hey look when it comes to practicing i
always worry about whether i'm doing it
the right way or not risking wasting
time i've seen a lot of if you practice
it this way you're wasting your time
bits
um i think that practice is always good
in and of itself i
the only thing i would say is that if
you're practicing a language what you
should do is always talk about stuff you
like sure that you get some feedback if
you're talking to someone
and and get feedback record the
conversation
and listen to it again and out of your
comfort zone try to say things you
cannot say
and do not worry about performing worry
about actually learning
these are the five things that you
should abide by when it comes to
uh practicing a language and the rest
doesn't matter don't listen to people
telling you do this do it this way do it
the other way just do it the way you
want to do it
as at the end of the conversation you
feel satisfied you went out you got out
of your comfort zone
you talked about something you liked and
you got feedback and you're going to
review it then you're going to be fine
uh so let me go down here will there be
a time when you will
yes but i don't know this i don't see
the rest of the question
uh hi luca regards from venezuela have
you studied latin i have
and i have latin was my favorite school
a favorite subject at school after five
years of high school
i was called the monster of the quintoa
this this is the
the la there legend has it right
they said that i uh i was famous at
school for latin because i was
i remember my latin teacher they gave us
like these um
version we call it in tiny i used to do
four or five in an hour and then i got
bored and i kept doing them once i did
eight of them in an hour
but not because i was i mean i think i
was good because i was learning by my
by myself again going back to what i was
saying before um
they gave us very easy texts to
translate so i was learning
uh latin out of my on my own because i i
loved it
and so i was way more skilled than
anybody else
and um and yeah i latin was one of my
favorite subjects at school
if you're learning ever learning latin i
highly recommend
you get this book this book is amazing
it's called familia romana pars so part
one
and you can see why from the very
beginning without knowing anything
anything of the language they just make
it comprehensible so it's a it's a it's
a text that you can read
and by reading it and looking at the
images you will
literally just to give an idea of how
this works
i don't know if you can see it i hope
you can so they have at the border of
the page this is how you should learn a
language
you know uh they they have conceived the
stacks so that
you can learn by following of a
roman family the story of a roman family
and then
you have descriptions you have you have
a number of amazing things that they
they let me see if you see the details
so they show
uh for example actions etc etc is just
amazing and i wrote
a very interesting piece on my blog
about how to learn latin or ancient
greek
as if it were a modern language maybe
kevin can put a link in there
so um kadeem do you think learning 500
most frequent words can help you learn a
language
sure but it's not just words to make a
difference you can learn
500 words the most important thing
though is to start creating sentences
that are useful for you to have conversa
meaningful conversations
so if you're just learning 500 most
frequent words it doesn't serve that
much
of of of a purpose but if you learn how
to use them and combine them
you will learn i we i have a video
my team and i we have a video in store
about learning a language
uh in learning to speak at a very basic
level in record time
if you're interested you'll you know
we're going to show you how to do that
it's going to be it's pretty it's a
pretty exciting project
and uh but again here the the main thing
is how to use those words in other words
it's not the pieces of information that
you that you uh collect
it's the way you use them how
uh g she i'm not sure i can pronounce
this g
[ __ ] mk how important is listening and
language learning very important the
more you listen
the better i would say so get into the
habit of listening as much as you can
but make sure that what you listen to is
at least comprehensible to a certain
degree 60
and one idea that i always one piece of
advice for people who have been learning
a language from one month
is to for example let's say that you've
been learning a language with asimil
uh for one month so just make sure that
you listen massively to the language to
all the material that you've already
covered so once you've understood the
first
you've gone through the first 30 lessons
then when you move on to the next
lessons
then keep listening to the ones you've
already done because it's
great comprehensible input and it helps
you retain
you know vocabulary because you review
it in a way
augustine says how do i how do i develop
and discipline well discipline is
something that you you you create by
doing it so the first thing i would say
is plan
plan things beforehand start small these
two things so every sunday
uh tomorrow just uh spend
ten minutes sitting down and thinking
what can i start learning uh portuguese
where is it that i feel fresh
if you don't plan and and you learn on
the spur of the moan so to speak and and
you depend on your willpower it's not
gonna happen it can happen for three
days it's not going to happen for a long
time so make sure that you
uh you plan beforehand and you start
small and then you can
increase the amount of time that you
spend on language on your portuguese
every single day
but 10 minutes a day is better than you
know 10 minutes
every day for in a week you know is
better than one hour just on saturdays
or sundays
what are the languages that make you
feel comfortable the most
i would say english french
spanish i feel great when i talk when i
speak these languages italian not so
much
but this is a little bit complex to to
to explain
uh but from a psychological point of
view i remember that i was in bergamo
because uh the the french teacher of the
school of this linguistic lychee
linguistico
she had invited me to hold a speech at a
theater
for her students and i gave the speech
while i was rehearsing both an english
and an italian and she was
struck by the fact that in english i
felt much more um
you know much more confident and that's
true when i speak english
i feel like there's a part of me you
know this luca here i'm standing and i'm
seeing myself speak and it's an amazing
feeling
it's just because in english english not
being my native language
i don't have all the social pressure all
the things
that have um you know
i've created an identity in italian so
by speaking this is my native language
and i don't have uh these things in
english english as a language i acquired
later
so it's really difficult to explain uh
in in words what i feel but when i speak
english i feel free
i don't know if that ever happened to
you guys but when you speak a foreign
language that if you speak it well you
you're liberated in a way so
um i'm going
here i'm going to the the very bottom so
i see also the questions that are
uh they're being here so as
leah hi luca would you be able to
comment on using glossik as a supplement
to textbooks in italki
i confess i do not know glossika i know
some students of mine
who have been using it so i cannot
really comment on that because i don't
know the system
why not asks which one is better to
improve vocabulary newspaper or book and
i i think in language learning you
should you should avoid asking questions
like is this better than that
i would always say both you can use the
newspaper
and the book you can read a newspaper
and the book they serve different
purposes
they have different uh language you know
they have a different kind of language
but i would say both i love reading news
newspaper pretty much every day i have a
pile of newspapers in my bathroom
and magazines and i also read books so
you get the best of both worlds
if you don't like the news because you
get stressed by them then you just focus
on books
um cute pets do people recognize you in
the streets
yes more and more everywhere i go that's
just amazing
uh because it's just mind-blowing you
know just like they want autographs
where they want pictures
and uh it fills me with joy because uh
it means that people follow me if they
recognize me more than me
what is important the message that i try
to convey it's the beauty about
you know the beauty of language learning
of speaking languages changing your life
and um and yeah it happened a lot and i
i had a lot of interesting experiences
you know of people i met on the street
recognized me on the street
so um
what has been the most immersive
immersive trip that you have
taken this is an interesting question
um i would say i always call you know it
depends on what you mean by trip
for me life is a trip but if you know i
would say that the most intensive
immersive trip i would say or experience
is in france where because i had
when i was with my uh french girlfriend
for five years
i basically lived like a french when i
was in paris
i lived with her parents for a couple of
months and i was visiting her parents
um a lot and they really liked french
culture
talking about culture movies they were
showing it was just amazing so it was
the most immersive experience i went i
was going to an interpreting school in
paris
so i was really surrounded by the
language and as i always say it doesn't
depend on where you live
depends on how you live but if you have
the where and how both in place then
it's amazing so i had
a french girlfriend i was just speaking
french with her her french family was
really
you know they were very educated people
loved talking about
literature poetry politics and
movies etc and on top of that i was
going to an interpreting school that
where they requested a very high level
in french and cultural understanding and
a grasp of the culture itself
so i would say that was the most
immersive trip if by
trippy mean experience then um
i want to go this uh this summer i'm
seriously contemplating the idea of
going to greece for two weeks to see
those i don't know if there's any greek
there there but i heard it's a beautiful
uh it's a beautiful
country and for the very first time
after some 25 years i'm going to go back
to school again
it's going to be exciting um luca your
team you have to do they also speak
multiple languages or at least more than
one yes
um the the the stuff the the thing i
really like about my team
kevin berta andre sophia is that they
we all love language learning we all
have
a mission you know this is not just a
venture this is not something we do for
money this is something we do for the
out of sheer passion
so they all learn a bunch of languages
um kevin
speak i think kevin i don't want to
speak on on your behalf but i think you
speak like six or
uh four four five or six um they all
been
apart from andre i think students of
mine so
uh we all share a love for languages uh
sophia speaks uh also a bunch of
languages berta speaks
as you know her native spanish uh
english
italian and french so yeah we we all
you know we all love language learning
and we all have a mission
that's why i love them so much apart
from the fact that they're wonderful
individuals
so it's fantastic jose says yes it's
perfect i can't wait to go to greece if
mr corona allows me to travel um
do you meditate in different languages
in your mind are there different
techniques to help you level up
i don't meditate in the languages it's
just meditation for me is just
letting actually thoughts go by and i
don't think in
in words when i meditate so i don't know
if you mean
that but when i meditate i just focus on
you know
taking a stand and looking at myself
from a different perspective from an
external perspective and observe myself
from the act
from the outside antonio where do you
actually live i live in rome
but i will be traveling i hope i will go
to munich
in a few weeks and then from germany i
will go to poland
for a couple of months and then
i should be either in berlin you know
should be around europe uh might also go
to budapest
uh and slovakia so that'll be a middle
europa as they call it
are you still doing japanese no i'm not
marley i'm not doing japanese for now
i'm working on three languages at the
same time i'm gonna make a video about
that
hungarian greek and danish and
but i'll go back to japanese fin
i don't know if i pronounce it right
maybe you're french i don't know i also
feel myself
i also feel different in other languages
could you say more about how your
personality sorts
sort of changes in other languages
i don't think that my personality
changes i always use the metaphor of the
prism
a prism when it's hit by the light a
prism you see it like
and then you see the light that is white
but when the prison
when the light hits the prism then you
see the different colors that make up
the light
that white array of light that hits the
prison
and i believe the language learning
makes makes you discover different sides
of your personality so the personality
is also
always the same but you touch different
colors of your personality so to speak
so when i speak english it's the part
that
that part of me is that luca as if luca
were born in the united states in a way
and the same the same happens when i
speak other languages like french or
spanish languages in which i have
really um you know i integrated the
culture
in me and i um it's just
like a lens that's that's why i always
say this speaking four languages makes
you see
a more cop you have more colors it makes
you see a more colorful world
but my personality in and of itself does
not change it's my vision of life it's
the amount of colors through which
i see the world that changes so
you apparently feel different maybe
you're not different it's just that
you're discovering a little bit more
yourself every single day
how do you travel relate to your work i
i when i got invited i
got invited to a ted talk i i couldn't
go with tedx actually uh
in france because of the pandemic and
that was a bummer because i wanted to
talk about the beauty of learning
languages but when i get invited to hold
to have workshops or conferences i
travel there but i normally travel and
work
i i can you know i
the only thing that suffers maybe is
that youtube videos they're more
difficult to do because i have all my
gear here and i have to buy some gear
that i can carry
around but fundamentally
i can travel from everywhere just a
second i have to i've been speaking on
stuff for one hour
and i have to drink a little bit
as he says it's nice to see you
okay now the chat here uh kenny velde
i again i answered the same for the
the question above i do not know i
haven't spoken as
so much as spoken mandarin in a long
time i made a video in other languages
uh in 11 languages recently but mandarin
chinese
and japanese are languages that are a
little bit they're in the back burner
they're suffering a little bit because i
use let's say between
six and nine languages every week but
portuguese swedish mandarin chinese and
in japanese or languages i speak less so
when i
learned it back in when i started
learning it back in 20
it was almost 12 years ago 13 years ago
i learned it to a decent level and i
remember i had a lot of fun
using a website i don't even remember
the name of it where you can
meet people and talk to them in chats
and then
you know the voice chat i think i got
into a b1 b2 level
but then i neglected it a little bit
and so i do not know exactly but the
good thing
that did not happen with i mean this
thing did not happen with chinese it did
happen unfortunately with japanese is
that
i know for a fact that if i go back to
chinese i'm gonna go back to it
pretty quickly so i'm not really
particularly worried about that and i
know the chinese is a very important
language
plus i discovered some amazing amazing
channels on youtube that i can't wait to
see
one is in particular it's called
mandarin corner i don't know if you guys
have ever heard of mandarin corner
also yoyo chinese is great but mandarin
corner is just fantastic
so it has like interviews on the streets
subtitles in in
in english and in chinese it's just
mind-blowing so
um you know it's just uh just amazing
how long would you spend an asthma when
beginning a language it depends i
normally spend like four or five months
but if you if you use it if when i
always tell my students if they apply
the bi-directional translation
technique it's normally three months but
you can also finish it in two months it
depends
i'm never in a hurry when it comes to
language learning so i took i take my
time
but you can finish the book in in three
months if you have 100
100 lessons and you go through one a day
and then you keep reviewing the
preceding ones
three four months uh are enough
have you ever gotten dianna salinas asks
have you ever gotten confused between
languages
oh now i i lost the question because
the the chat so i can't find your
question anymore but the answer is
sometimes yes oh i found it again
sometimes i get confused
when it comes to speaking some languages
that are similar maybe i've been using
german a lot then i have to use dutch
for the reasons i was just telling
speaking about before talking about
before
and it depends it i can get confused if
i have it happened i have a bunch of
friends
from all over the world at home and over
dinner and then
i found myself speaking one language
hear one language there the other
language there and then
it can get confusing if everybody speaks
it speaks to me in a different language
but in general i don't if i speak one
language and i've been speaking that
language for quite some time with one
person i don't get confused it really
depends on a number of circumstances
is reading more effectively listening if
you only have time for one activity
learning two languages at the same time
and consider reading in one and
listening to the other interesting
question
um i think they're both effective i
think would
i think ultimately it depends on your uh
it depends on your level it depends on
your goal
it depends on a number of factors if
you're a beginner you should read and
listen at the same time
if you just read and you don't listen
you don't get to hear how the language
is spoken you won't understand your
listening comprehension will be bad but
if you
just listen and read very little then
you will be
i don't i wouldn't go so far as to say
illiterate but it will be a little bit
more difficult
i would say if you have 20 minutes of
your time a day just do 10 minutes of
listening or 10 minutes of reading or
read and listen at the same time
you get the best of both worlds
so um i don't feel those emotions as
powerful as in english
she doesn't know how i can drink fidel i
don't know
i don't know why well you know to each
his own as they say
so what's the best way to improve
listening comprehension is to listen to
a lot and listening to comprehensive
comprehensible
input so always make sure that whatever
your level if you want to
if you still do not understand very well
a language very well make sure you
always
either watch a video with subtitles or
you listen with a pod with a transcript
when you're listening to a podcast
and when you reach the decent level make
sure that you listen at least 30 minutes
a day because listening is very
important
as i said before plan plan your
listening
and then just make it happen on a on a
on a regular basis what i do is for
example i build uh
you know a habit of just listening to
polish every single time i take a shower
i have my
i don't know where they are right now my
airpods so if i don't have to wash my
hair
i just listened so i i finished trading
work out or running and then i always
uh you know my my brain automatically
tells me
it's polish time so in that in those 20
minutes i always listen to
to polish and building habits is much
better than relying on willpower
so plan beforehand build habits and make
listening
a priority whatever your level because
it does make a difference if you do it
every day
how would you gauge your arabic
currently i don't speak i don't
speak uh arabic michel so i
i just rate it as zero beginner i think
um i don't i don't speak a word of
arabic now that i think about it maybe i
can see a couple
but very very few uh giovanni scalius
can eventually the method of a chat all
japanese all the time what do you think
of this method i do not know the method
in detail um i have recently talked to
um to another polyglot who talks about
the
the method uh ajax all japanese all the
time i would just say
i know about the concept of massive
immersion
if you want to immerse yourself
massively there's no harm in doing that
it's great for some it's not great for
others because some people
have the you know the will of immersing
themselves and just dedicate themselves
to that language and
and you know but if if you have other
fish to fry
if you're very busy if you're very busy
if you have a family if you have
other languages to tackle then it might
be more difficult to do it in practice
but the idea in and of itself is great
the more
the more you're the more time you you
spend with a language and you have your
phone in the language you watch movies
in the language you do stuff in the
language the better
um how long does it take you to learn
russian
so in general if you say how long does
it take in general to learn russian
that's a question how long it took me
um and is it hard to learn yes it's a
hard
uh language to learn if you don't speak
any slavic
language so it depends on your native
language as always if
your native language is ukrainian or
slovak
or um or polish for that matter it's
much easier if you don't speak any of
these languages
then it gets a little bit complicated
sorry for the dog sparking it always
starts at the same time
both of them and um
norma how long it took me i really don't
know i started in 2014 but i didn't
practice the language at all after a
year and then as i said before i met my
ex-girlfriend and it changed
everything so when in 2013 i started
you know dating my ex-girlfriend and it
you know i started using the language
all the time
so i'm really not sure it you know it's
it's really
uh it can be misguiding to say i started
at this time because i ca
i count more you should count the amount
of hours you spend with the language
more than when you started
i would say i i'm not sure but after i
after i met my
my ex-girlfriend i was really motivated
and i started learning on it you know
not only speaking with her but also
what doing a bunch of stuff and it went
very quickly but i would say normally
if your russian is not if you don't
speak any slavic language
it might take you a couple years to
start speaking it decently because
russian is a tough
nut to crack as as they say
um so
what do you think of duolingo pimsleur i
don't use duolingo or pimsleur so i
confess that i do not know but if you
want to use duolingo and or pimsleur you
can maybe it would be the cherry on top
i think you say cherry on top and i'm
wrong but i would not use them as the
your main resources to tell you the
truth but again i i don't know because
i've i've never used them but
i i hear that they're not they're
more like to get entertained you know
more than
rather than learning they're very
popular but i'm not sure whether they're
really great tools to learn a language
or keep improving um jason do you have
any advice to get motivated to study a
language again after one
lost your fluency i yes i to get
motivated i think you have to
one thing that i would do is to sit down
and visualize yourself in the future
one year from now think about what you
can do with that language think with
your emotions don't think with your
with your prefrontal cortex as i call it
here think with your limbic system
because we a lot of people don't
you know the emotions are not in the in
the in the
discourse they're not addressed when it
comes to language learning
but they're very important to get
motivated you need emotions
you don't need instructions remember
that you need emotions you don't need
instruction so
um to get emotions involved you need to
visualize yourself in the future get
connected with a with with a person
find a person who talked to you online
if you don't know
if you've lost contact with locals you
have to do something that
that really sparks the interest again
and that has to do with emotions
whatever
it is be it watching a movie reading a
book going to the country
speaking with a person visualizing
yourself in the future but
if you have to get the ball rolling when
it comes to again
the emotional side of learning because
it's really important at the end of the
day that's what makes us stick
what binds us what compels us what
compels me for that matter is being able
to
embrace new worlds talk to new people
savor
uh savor new different kinds of foods
see
places this is what makes me tick this
is the reason why i learn languages
in and of itself the language is
exciting but words do not excite me
grammar grammar explanations do not
excite me
what excites me is the possibility of
again living new experiences
through another lens and through
different colors that's what excites me
and i think that's what should excite
you as well
so um
uh what language are you thinking
interesting i
think when i get mad i i think in
italian but i also think in english and
i find myself speaking english more than
i wake up in the morning and i speak
english to myself not italian
and i see languages in a way
english is more like for work for more i
plan in english so when i have to plan
stuff and be
more rational so to speak i use english
for other languages i use
you know for for other things to use
different languages but in general
mainly italian english and sometimes
spanish which are actually the languages
i'm using the most
so maybe it makes sense
but i've dreamed in all languages in all
languages i know
so uh
so uh free should someone who's learned
thousands of words
through reading but never spoke back to
beginner material practice
that's an interesting question so let me
read it again should someone who's
learned thousands of words for reading
but never spoke go back to beginner
material no i think you should just
practice speaking
so just collect your words if you want
to but get to practice
you know you can read as much as you
want but if your goal is to
apart from reading is to practicing a
language speaking a language then you
have to go
starting you have to start speaking a
language and
in that regard going back to what i said
before maybe you can find someone to
talk to in a protected environment and
start speaking
because reading is great but speaking is
even better actually no they're both
great
so what book can you recommend for
learning japanese
um i would say one of the best books you
one of the best investments now it's
difficult to grab it for whatever reason
is this
this is a great book for any language
you want to learn it's called
japanese sentence patterns for effective
communication because what i really like
about this book is that it focuses on
coming
on communication focuses on actually
using
the words and pieces of lego to convey
meaningful messages rather than learning
a bunch of words
and uh and sentences so you can get all
the books you want but this one is going
to really help you
when it comes to communicating in
japanese and there's a there's
15 other books i have there but we're
you know running out of time so maybe
next time
uh we can talk about that or again guys
you can always go
on to my blog and leave questions there
you can you can send me uh questions i
receive a lot of questions
i don't dress all of them every day
because you you know there's a lot of
them but
probably we'll create a session where
you you can you can
ask your questions and we'll collect all
of them
so um let me see uh was babel very
useful for you i made a vid
a couple of videos with babel and never
used it so i'm not a
babble guy or because i've never used it
i just work with them making videos
they're fantastic guys i really like i
when i was in berlin i worked with them
but i do not use
the their app i heard that it's a good
app to use
but i do not do not know it so
i uh i don't know
what what's your method to learn
languages it would take me four hours to
explain that so
uh you know unfortunately i can't really
address this question now
um again guys we're gonna i'm gonna keep
answering questions for the next 20
minutes so until
so it's going to be 1 hour 45 minutes
but you know we can save the chat so we
will we'll
we're we're collecting all the questions
we're asking and
we we hope we can you know answer all of
them
in some somehow some some questions are
recurring questions so
if you watch also the uh q a live the
first one you will see that
um uh you know you you can find
more information maybe maybe if i
haven't answered your question you can
find more information on the other
and the other one um in the other q a
how do you maintain your languages i
think i reply to this question before i
create a lifestyle i'm losing
juan asks i'm losing a lot of words when
i'm listening how do you solve this
i'm not sure what you mean by losing a
lot of words but i guess that you you if
you mean
miss a lot of words in the sense that
you don't understand them
well you can go back to the drawing
board as so to speak and you can start
listening and reading at the same time
until your listening comprehension gets
really good and then
and then you know you can go back to
just listening to a language
if you miss a lot of words it means that
your listening comprehension is not good
or you're choosing material that is not
particularly
you know it's not proper or it's not
great for your current level
um is it possible to learn language for
free on the internet yes
you can learn a language for free on the
internet if you can if you can but if
you if you want to invest
some time in figuring out the know-how
or
find tutors who can help you that speeds
up the process but the answer is yes
you can but it might take a little bit
longer than usual
but the answer is yes you can nowadays
just use the internet you're paying for
your internet connection but apart from
that you can do amazing things nowadays
so uh elisabetka
asks a question that has been asked a
lot of times
and it's really interesting we're
learning of languages disappear due to
translating technologies i've heard from
one polygon
it may be a matter of 15 years what do
you think i don't think the language
learning will ever disappear
it's the same thing as asking for
example oh do you remember when they
were saying
that paper books were doomed because you
had the
the kindle the rising on the kindle
never happened because people still use
and a lot of people prefer paper books
so
directly speaking a foreign language of
the human being is an act of love
language learning builds speaking
languages builds
bridges among cultures and the
as much as you know you can find a
wonderful electronic voice
in between the two of you two people
speaking but it will never replace the
beauty of human communication through
direct human communication through a
language you know and
and as i said language learning speaking
a foreign language builds worlds
connects people
and so technologies will for sure will
be very useful to connect more more and
more people
that can't speak a commonly they don't
speak a common language but i don't
think it's
i don't think that they're going to
disappear not in 15 years now in 30
years
not in 100 years so
um abby can i continue learning vocab
simply from reading and listening or do
you think it's worth
trying some kind of flashcard vocab
method i think the list
the more you listen and the more you
read the better or the more you listen
and read at the same time but if you can
find also a way to deliberately
kind of review somehow the words or
fragments that you keep learning
so much the better i do both i expose
myself massively to a language
but i i don't demand merely by listening
and reading i will absorb the language
um because
that's i don't think that that's the way
it works um
stephen krashen talks about it like
incomprehensible input and i agree with
that
but i also have my own opinion and i've
recently read a very interesting speech
by a japanese linguist that talks about
the fact that
linguists recently tend to lean towards
a hypothesis in which the liver practice
facilitates the acquisition of a
language so in
to to answer your question is do both
get exposed passively but also make sure
that you design a system
where you review words because your
brain is going to thank you for it
let's go to the very bottom of the chat
so the last
15 minutes uh i've been running a
marathon here
or where are the best places to watch
read about language learning research uh
well
you the internet i know that this is a
little bit vague but
if you do some research you will find a
lot of interesting books
it's just maybe you should avoid stuff
that is a little bit too academic but
i've
found a lot of stuff i will probably put
it in the resources section on my blog
if you're interested in linguistics you
i've read a bunch of books
and i have them all there linguistics
but it depends on your goal again so
so
let me go up here
hey look at you speaker plan to speak
catalan at some point i'm curious
because i'm a catalan native speaker i
always joke with berta
but uh she's a member of my team she's
from madrid
and i try to speak fake catalan you know
but the reality is i'm interested in the
language i like it and i wish
i had started learning it when i was in
barcelona for five months
i i attended all lectures in catalan
so i understand it decently but i've
never really
uh i've never really learned it i would
like to learn in one day i don't think
it's going to take me a long time to
learn it because it's a
i you know already speaking i'm a native
time speaker
i speak french speak spanish so it's
catalan is a combination of these
languages in a way
so i i've been i've been toying with the
idea of learning catalan one day
i might give it a shot or i might when
if if one day i moved to barcelona
which is one of my favorite cities in
europe i definitely might give it a shot
do you plan to take tests to value or
level in certain languages yes
i've taken five tests four tests p2
c2 and now i would like to pass the c1
in pola in polish
maybe in warsaw at the end of the year
and i will document it if i can
when i go to poland so
uh uh
are there any polling resources for the
visually impaired i confess
jd that i do not know i don't know about
this
so i can really reply to this question i
wish i knew but i i
i don't um um
hey lucas what is the best book to learn
german there is no best book there is
just a book that is
is the best for you you know there are
no best resources
you know for any language i would it
depends if you're a beginner i
have i have used my own resource which
is called the
agostini birthday that was back in 1996
i think ostimal is a great resource but
once again i think you have to
spend invest some time in doing some
research and find the resource that
works best for you
do you still study english
systematically i think i've answered
this question before is it possible to
become fluent in seven days
um well if by fluent you mean saying a
couple of sentences then yes but if by
fluent you mean to be able to
communicate
in a language in a meaningful way then
the answer is no
if you'll see all these stunts on the
internet of
learning a language in seven days
the problem with these titles is that is
fluent is a very
very vague word that means nothing and
everything at once
so it generates a lot of discussions and
a lot of um you know i wouldn't go so
far as to say is hatred but
um no lord to me learning
learning to speak and to use a language
in a meaningful way takes years no
matter which language
some languages are easier it takes less
to learn because they're more
they're closer to yours catalan for
example i think it would take me three
months to
start speaking decently in catman i
wouldn't go i wouldn't say fluent
but seven days forget about it
um let me see here uh
luca como penderon is to learn language
from scratch
this is a this is a good question okay
someone else
asked me but that's quite complex you
can you can actually
go to my blog and there's quite a few um
actually articles maybe kevin you can
you can
if you search uh how to learn a language
from scratch look around on google you
will find some articles to talk about
that there's a lot of
interesting pieces of advice hopefully
and i you can also listen remember on my
blog you can listen to all the articles
you can read and listen especially
the last 100 i think articles i've been
reading the
the article out loud so you can you know
listen and read so you can practice
um ruslan says russian is not a
difficult
well if you're russian yes that's not
that complicated
when you come to poland will there be a
possibility to meet you kaya
i mean i i i said it on on on facebook
and on instagram that when i
when i went to krakow when i went to i
will i will be in krakow
varshava and yeah if you want to meet
i've met a lot of people there and
i think because of the pandemic we
cannot do a you know meet up
but if you wanna if you wanna meet just
send me a message on instagram um
or on facebook and and and then we can
make it happen
i i love meeting people so um
you know whoever wants to meet when i'm
in poland or in munich uh let me know
and
and if i have the time i'd be delighted
to see you guys
how do you learn cases eliseo uh lisa i
have uh
we have a couple of articles on my blog
very detailed about how to learn cases
kevin can can can post a link so
you should definitely check that out
you've write how to learn cases you will
see that
for a lot of there's a lot of
information and i've made a youtube
video about that
jose luis electric
i'm an electronic engineer i'm
specialized in
particle accelerators i can see my
thesis
so it's this is in english actually it's
uh
generating the plasma so uh accelerated
protons
plasma interaction so was i you know
particle accelerators
i wrote this thesis in english this is
the second thesis i have
my second degree i have anyway
so i'll put it here um yeah my
you know i love mathematics quantum
mechanics physics
and particle accelerators but i don't
talk about the stuff on
on the internet uh you know because this
this channel is mainly about language
learning but yeah i have
a bunch of other interests apart from
that and if you guys like
um if you would like me to talk about
productivity
uh growth you know personal growth etc
even mathematics how to do that i can do
that
so um
it's a very interesting question in
french
he's associations me if i'm associating
different aspects of a language
um it it happens
it happens sometimes um i use i leverage
the
the you know i leverage the the
knowledge i have in
in certain languages to learn others but
i don't i do not unless it's strictly
necessary i do not use a language
i don't i think the term is
triangulation triangulate
so i don't spend uh i don't think that
it's exciting to
learn russian through french you know i
just use italian
but um
so pedro asked the question how long it
took you to learn russian maybe you read
it before
so while your knowledge is really
impressive thing on things a bunch
uh well i love learning so i've
this is something that came from my
family uh
my grandmother took me like some 20
years ago she asked me
hey do you want to learn some latin
french remember was a summer school it's
an episode i recall
very fondly and she instilled uh
the power the beauty of learning so i've
been learning i've been a
you know a learner for for as long as i
remember and i love learning everything
every every single day i wake up at five
and i
you know sometimes 5 30 sometimes six
today i woke up at eight i was very
tired
but i love learning all day long you
know uh coach
luca i may be saying senile school have
you ever thought of learning at school
i'm building my own language academy
guys you should sign up
you know so uh i've never i've never
thought of
teaching because i've been you know i
have a degree in engineering and then
immediately i started learning as a
you know working as a coach but
um but yes i will build a language
language learning academy and you guys
as i said you shine and sign up it's
going to be cool
quantity you use quantum mechanics ivan
says to learn
languages not exactly lofoten how old
are you i'm 40.
i just i just i just turned 40 on the
17th of december 20
20 20. so at the ripe age of 40
you know i still i have some you can see
some whites
right here here so i'm getting old
how many hours do you sleep around eight
hours i made it the most important thing
now is sleeping asleep for me so sleep
nutrition and motion are the most
important things then
concentration this is the fourth thing
and then language learning and disorder
what do you think about esperanto i
don't know i don't know the language
i've never
felt compelled to learn it but i it's a
very good idea it's a it's a very
interesting idea
the founder i was like 100 years ago or
a little bit more
and i think it's great to get started in
a foreign language because
i heard that it's very it's a rather
simple language that is not just great
been conceived to facilitate um
you know communication uh among peoples
different peoples
but also um you know in general it's a
language learning tool that you can use
to
understand the mechanics and dynamics of
language learning
do you speak romanesco doesn't exist
anymore i i speak
i it's not a dialect but yes with my
friends we speak a weird language that
other italians don't understand
that's my natural language actually
roman italian i would say then italian
as a second language i speak
how many hours do you speak okay wait
so it's scrolling i'm scrolling up
and michael do you think asthma is one
of the best things one can do to start
learning a language it's not one
of the best things you can do it's one
of the best resources you can use
depending on the language yes i would
say
it's a great resource if you want to
learn a bunch of languages uh
i wouldn't recommend it for asian
languages because it's less good
but yes if you want to learn romanian
french german spanish
and whatnot um i think it's a great
resource we still have five minutes guys
so how do you write how do you practice
your life writing skills this is another
very good one
i i keep a journal every day i wake up
every single day and i write a journal
but i do it in italian and for other
languages i have different techniques
i haven't so much i haven't talked about
writing
on my blog true so we will write this is
a very good idea i will
i'll uh i'll write about writing you
know meta skill
and by the way i have
recently i wanted to show you guys just
a second because it's not here it's here
if you have if you have um some time
to in energy to invest on a meta skill
i would definitely get this book i don't
know if you can see it
it it's how to take smart notes by sunk
fantastic book about if you want to
one simple technique to boost writing
learning and thinking for students
academics and non-fiction book writers
highly recommend it because it teaches
you the beautiful art of writing
in any language so um
funny mistranslation story there's
there's quite a few
uh actually but we'll i'll tell you more
about it maybe in the next
in the last live q a very interesting
funny episodes in my life about
you know misinterpret misinterpreting
and mistranslations
if you had all the money in the world
what would you buy and why
i i wouldn't buy necessarily anything i
don't think the money
first of all i don't think the money
makes a difference but it makes
it makes for a better life i would maybe
i wouldn't buy
anything physical i would buy myself an
experience i would go to new zealand
that's what i would do
i would spend the money that i i have to
spend to go to new zealand and spend
three months there in the mountains and
then
to spend time at the beach and explore
new zealand in general this is what i
would do
i like spending money for to for
experiences not so much
books sure but again i spend money on
books to have the experience of reading
a book not
to have the book in and of itself i've
learned that hat
being is much more important than just
having so if i had all the money in the
world i would spend most of my time
traveling and exploring the world
because life is short
and the world is bigger is bigger than
one things and stuff will
explore it all in one lifetime
what would be the best way to teach
germans the sense of humor
i don't know about that you know i i
think i
i had a lot of fantastic uh german
friends i don't think that germans do
not have
sense of humor they just have a
different sense of humor but thanks for
the question
uh fifa said oh that was a fantastic
life thanks a lot
um thank you guys for watching we have
still three minutes
um uh thank you thank you for all the
enthusiasm all the questions i want to
leave you by
telling you that i think we will do more
of these
q a q a live sessions in the future
we might do another one maybe in a month
uh always in english and then we might
start venturing into other languages
maybe
you know there i received a lot of
requests for making this kind of live
q a in spanish so maybe we could do a
spanish one both for native spanish
speakers who want to learn more about
language learning because i talk about
all the time i speak english and a lot
of
requests are you know hey luke i want to
make a video in italian and make a video
in spanish i make it i
as much as i would like to do that i
also want to keep the content of this
youtube channel consistent and it's
about language learning or learning how
to learn
and with english i can serve uh a wider
audience but this doesn't mean that i'm
not gonna go
and do more more videos uh and also more
live
videos in in other languages i would i
would say spanish would be next
and then italian for and then we will
see if we want to make other videos in
other languages why not
i you know i always like having contact
with you guys and and speaking uh
and you know you have fantastic
questions and
really this is this is exciting energy
energizing for me
because um i really appreciate all the
enthusiasm the questions
uh you know it's just great
so let's recap i hope that this was
useful
this was uh especially that's the most
important thing that this was
first and foremost useful um i'm sorry
if i skipped some of the questions i had
some of the questions here uh that i
read some
but i skipped others so sorry about the
about that but again um if we do more
live videos i will answer more and more
questions and then you can re-watch
these videos
whenever you want because we're going to
be on the internet very
very shortly in in about the next 20
minutes
and thank you all for the enthusiasm for
the the right questions for the
for the for the nice questions for the
energy the positive energy
keep talking guys remember learning a
language or two or three
languages can change your life it's not
just sitting down and learning
it's just connect and remember
connecting with different worlds think
about it for a second speaking a foreign
language
can potentially connect you with
millions of people
and that isn't on itself is just one of
the many reasons why
you should learn a foreign language
thank you guys
uh and uh oh yeah and it's never too
late
yeah thank you guys uh and i'll see you
if things go well and i go according to
plan uh i'll see you in a month
you know at the last sunday of the month
we might have another
uh one of these q a thank you hugs and
kisses
from rome and keep keep rocking and keep
learning
languages bye bye ciao